c'est un des gros casse-tête de la crise
comment assurer la sécurité des
éducateurs et le bien-être des enfants
sans les étouffer sous les règlements
les interdit simplement en écoutant ce
que dit la science pense un millier de
médecins signataires d'une pétition qui
réclame un retour rapide à la normale
pour les moins de 12 ans je pense qu'un
enfant qui comprend tous deux ou trois
mois dans sa vie c'est rien un enfant de
deux ans trois ans deux trois mois dans
leur vie ça commence à être inquiétant
je trouve ce que dit la science et que
très peu de jeunes enfants sont infectés
par l'aco vide que les cas graves sont
rares la mortelle des presque nulle et
le risque de transmission est faible là
on a l'impression qu'on a le recul pour
dire que ça se compose les bénéfices qu
bénéfices et les risques on croit que
c'est plus d'un majeur pour les enfants
moins de 12 ans d'avoir toutes ces
mesures là sur leur développement les
impacts psychologiques à moyen et long
terme
les médecins sujet donc d'éliminer la
règle de distanciation le port du masque
la désinfection des jouets et du
matériel éducatif
ils demandent le retour des activités
sportives dans le milieu des services de
garde la pétition était bien sûr partage
l'inquiétude des pédiatres là le fait
que si ces mesures le satyre d'antan il
pourrait y avoir des impacts sur le
développement des tout-petits en milieu
de garde faut-il le rappeler il n'y a eu
que huit enfants infectés depuis un mois
au québec on est ouvert aux
assouplissements
mais on pense qu'il faudrait avoir le
mécanisme pour en discuter et réévalué
en continu considérant que la situation
est sans précédent dans secteur de
l'enseignement la réponse est plus
mitigé on n'est pas surpris de voir
cette sortie là par contre nous ce qu'on
va chercher à travers soit celle
équilibre entre le développement
essentiel des enfants mais aussi la
sécurité du personnel et des familles
boni
les enfants vont bien quant au directeur
de la santé publique il a semblé réagir
positivement aux demandes des médecins
les garderies les écoles sont ouvertes à
l'extérieur font que ça va bien ça va
nous aider à changer probablement même
nous en sommes par rapport à la rentrée
scolaire de l'automne
ici normand grondin radio canada
montréal